hi i'm michelle klein member of the gsb
alumni association board and i'm pleased
to welcome you to this production
change organization yeah
change the world
[Music]
if not you
then who
then who you are sitting here
on the precipice of leaving
the gsb with the whole world in front of
you and you can do anything
and yet some of you are not sure what
your next step is
some of you are not sure if your job is
the perfect fit
and some are
wondering what were these two years
about
am i any less confused than when i
started
the point of today
is to let you know that you are
absolutely prepared for this next step
that you all have super powers you're
all unique and talented and you inspire
me every single day
so we're going to talk about my life
lessons
and i'm going to wrap it around stories
you know i love storytelling
so let's get started something you won't
believe because here i am
kind of a pushy new yorker telling you
all these things you should be doing but
i was the shyest kid
i hid behind my mom
and it would take a lot for me to speak
up in class or put myself out there
i grew up with a twin brother
adam
uh yeah we were dressed that way um i
had i grew up with an older sister jane
a lot of my uh students know that she
sends me beautiful clothes they're
called jane me downs
and um she protected me as well but
around age nine my personality started
to come and i got a little sassy
i even made some questionable fashion
choices
see elite i know you're very good with
fashion i don't know what you'd think of
my
my tartan cape here but uh it definitely
made me stand out
but through the years i came out of my
shell i had these life experiences and
these jobs and i i got my toolkit
and what i've learned is that everything
you experience is something you can
leverage even if it's a skill that's
dormant and you haven't used it in a few
years you can unearth it and bring it
out at the right
moment so here i am now in front of all
of you and i'm going to share some of my
beliefs and my principles and
these are my principles to live i'm
going to read it because i can't
memorize them but i'm going to go over
today about leading with love when sad
or disappointed help someone else
compassion over aggression
figure out how to connect to others
showing faith in others leads to their
success
let people know who you are by telling
your stories
listen when people tell you who you are
be accountable own your words and
actions it's not what happens it's how
you deal with it all my reputation
management people know that i believe in
that
and then of course create your own
narrative i must say that a hundred
times
and then finally which i teach in
executive presence
opt in and then figure it out
but don't hold yourself back out of fear
so here i actually emily covered this
all so i don't really have to say
anything but i've been here nine years
and i created a co-created a course
reputation management with jd sram that
was my gateway class into here to my
drug addiction to the gsb
and um and then i created
project u and strategic pivoting in the
two electives
so today hopefully you will learn from
my past and hopefully it can help the
future
my first lesson is disappointment can
lead to something even better
when i was at camp summer camp new york
city kids got sent away for two months
to summer camp because their parents
needed to get them out of the way
and i was auditioning for godspell i
think i was about nine years old and the
summer before i had been wendy in peter
pan and i killed it so i'm like i'm a
shoe-in for god's spell
and not only did i not get a role but i
didn't even get in the chorus so i go
back to my cabin and like sit on my bed
and i'm like feeling so sorry for myself
and feeling like misunderstood and my
counselor comes over and like alison
the youngest girls in bunk two are
putting on a play why don't you go help
them
so it's like okay
so i went down to bunk two and for the
next two weeks i was the director and
the costumer and the person who
practiced with them and the producer and
these kids put on a wonderful play
through that for some reason i got girl
of the week and then eventually i got
color captain and i had a reputation as
being a leader at my summer camp
if i'd gotten into god's spell yeah i
might have been good but none of that
would have happened and the lesson
wouldn't have been learned for me
i really believe this that when you have
difficult people in your life
it's a challenge but it's how you handle
it my mom taught me
that first of all you should lead with
love
but she also told me that when someone
is upset with you or angry or bullying
it's because they're coming from a place
of hurt
hurt people
she's like try to think maybe they're
going through a rough time
maybe something's happening in their
home life show compassion
so i'm sure many of you have been in a
situation where fire meets fire
someone's
when people
are coming at you they want that
interaction they want to engage you in a
way
that can provoke them so they can let
out all that anger and frustration but i
really believe that if you meet fire
with a warm blanket and compassion and
empathy
well then you'll be a greater
understanding and you can get things
done
when you meet someone who's angry with
compassion say you seem really upset can
i help in any way or something's going
on what's going on with you you'll see
all of a sudden the whole body language
just goes down like oh this is so
frustrating and then you're like how can
i help and all of a sudden
there's humanity
now i wish so this is the takeaway you
can only control your actions
how many times you said if only they had
said this or they should have done this
and i always say yeah they should have
but they didn't so how does that affect
you
how do you want to show up what's the
leader that you want to be
how would you handle the situation all
you can do is show up the way you want
to show up and role model it and not let
someone else's bad behavior affect you
now it'd be lovely if i took my own
advice but i didn't
and i had to learn the hard way
when i was at the home shopping network
which was run by barry diller and diane
von furstenberg
i came over from good morning america
and my job was to
control the home department all the
products that had to do with garden and
kitchen and that's a whole other story
because i don't cook and i don't garden
but i really am
as bert alper says don't let the truth
get in the way of a good story
so anyway i went over there to produce
and they matched you up with the
producing partner and they matched me up
with this woman amy amy had her own
reputation she was known as difficult
and sarcastic and kind of a malcontent
so when she first met she goes allison
she goes i'm so glad i'm partnered with
you i hear you're really friendly
everybody loves you i hate people
so you're going to be my buffer and i'm
thinking red flag i'm like in so much
trouble but you know what i'm like i'm
going to make this work maybe we can
balance each other out out
so after two weeks our talent quit and
they said alison you go on air you sell
products
and i was like okay
and so amy felt betrayed and abandoned
by me and she was so angry at me and she
would try to
not even passive aggressively she just
tried to undermine me she turned our
whole team against me and she made
comments about me you're all too young
to know the movie all about eve but it's
about a woman who'll do anything to get
into the movies so she would call me eve
anyway i asked her
if i could go to my husband's
law school graduation she says no you
can't go we need you
and she said you're so lucky i'm so
understanding always and then i did the
wrong thing i escalated and i said no
you've been a total
oh god first and only time i've used
profanity
and oh boy it just after that she would
talk in my ear doing live shows it got
so much worse
and
all i realized is that moment of
satisfaction when i got to say what i
really felt
it didn't it wasn't worth it i should
have been strategic
i should have figured out how to get
what i want and i didn't
and so that momentary feeling of saying
those bad words and what you feel it
doesn't pay off i lost all control and
it really blew up in my face
so my lesson for that is take control
and power and only i can take care of
how i react to things
so you're not a pushover though if you
do this you're still a leader because
you're going to show empathy you're
going to rely on facts to make your
argument
you're going to come up with solutions
you're going to set boundaries hopefully
and
i don't know if anyone recognizes this
gentleman probably mary spicer does
because we're colleagues
this was joel siegel from good morning
america
he was a correspondent for movies and
when i was an intern at gma he used to
take me to free screenings because i was
such an eager intern and i loved him
when i started working right out of
college for some reason he likes to haze
the new people and he came and he yelled
at me in front of a whole bunch of
people and i was so humiliated but i was
also really hurt because i really
admired him
but i didn't say anything but the next
day we were at the mailboxes because in
those days that's how he communicated
through mailboxes and he comes up like
hey allison and i'm like hi joel i said
joel i am so upset with how you talked
to me yesterday
um first of all it was very
unprofessional and second of all it
wasn't warranted and i really like you
and i admire you
and i love working with you
but i can't talk to you right now
because of what you did to me yesterday
you could have blown him over i was 21.
and
but i had boundaries and i knew if i
didn't set a precedent right he might do
it again and he said allison i'm so
sorry he talked like that allison um
and he's like i'm so sorry and you know
he never did it again and we were very
close
so there's something what i'm trying to
say is that
the exception is if abuse is consistent
and then you have to report it but
otherwise
you can tell anybody anything
as long as you say it in a nice way as
long as you say it in a calm way
so my next tip is connect to others on a
human level
when i was at penn my first year i took
psychology it was between psychology and
tv by the way just so you know
and
there was this study called the
bystander effect i'm sure you've heard
of it it's where
people if it's a group of people and
someone's screaming for help no one does
anything
there was a very big
case called the kitty genovese case
where a woman was stabbed in a courtyard
and screamed and no one came out to help
her but what the study said is if you
can single one person out and connect to
them as a human being
it's much more likely that they will
help you
so don't scream like fire on a train
like go up to someone and say i need
your help
so i remembered this and i had an
experience i was in london my junior
year i was studying abroad
and because i was a city girl i loved
taking the tube i thought it was much
better than the new york city subway and
i was coming back from the library and
it was 11 30 at night
and i got out on the platform and it
didn't occur to me how late it was and
it was it was deserted
and i get out and
a group of young men who are obviously
drunk came out of a carriage a few down
and they see me and they start screaming
at me and heckling me hey miss america
hey miss america and i my heart stopped
i'm like oh my god i'm going to be in a
bad situation why wouldn't i anticipate
this
and i remembered this and i started
walking towards them
and i said hey how'd you know i was
american was it my down jacket and
sneakers that gave it away
and then i went right up to the guy who
was obviously the leader
and i said hey can you do me a favor
i need someone to walk me home it's late
and
you guys look like you can protect me
would you walk me home and they said
sure and i put my hand through this arm
of this guy and i'm like so where are
you guys going it looks like you're
celebrating my heart was like oops my
heart was pounding and they became my
brothers
and they walked me home
now
it was risky and i'm not saying that'll
work
but that's what i was thinking about
i was thinking about connecting and
humanizing and not escalating a
situation that could have gone a
different way i really believe that that
eye contact
the humanity that people share can help
you in a sticky situation
all right
strange picture right there's definitely
a story about this
my next tip show faith in others i'm at
good morning america
that gentleman over there is ron reagan
jr president reagan's son and he was a
correspondent for gma
and we had to do this really boring
piece on how the lights are changed for
the empire state building
and so every holiday they change it and
we were going to interview
the inventor of the lights and the
billboards in new york
and we were like this is the most boring
piece that we're stuck so ron has this
great idea he goes i've got a great idea
it's the empire state building you'll be
fey ray and we'll get someone in a
monkey suit and in every shot they'll be
king kong chasing you or carrying you
while you're flailing and it'll be a
running joke and we're like brilliant
hysterical
so i had this intern matt had a little
crush on me and i threw him a bone i'm
like matt would you like to be in a
monkey suit for the shoot and he's like
yes please
so um
we go to the empire state building we're
on the 88th floor on the balcony um
ron's inside with this really boring i
mean this nice older man interviewing
him
and
i'm in matt's arms with my arms around
his neck and i'm waiting for the
director to say action
and then i do something i shouldn't have
done i said matt whatever you do don't
drop me
and they go action and he takes one step
trips falls
drops me on my back and falls on top of
me
monkey cement sandwich not good
i had to do the take 42 more times with
a bad back
what i did is i made this poor guy
nervous i didn't show faith in him
right if i had just said this is going
to be fun let's do it and i've learned
through my own life that when someone
shows doubt to me i doubt myself so as a
leader i try to be empowering and i try
to say you can do this i believe in you
it's the best gift you can give to
somebody
because if you they think you doubt them
they're going to doubt themselves and
they're not going to perform to their
best ability
if you treat me like an idiot i'm going
to act like one
by the way matt got me a nice bag of
kiwis to apologize i really liked kiwis
back then
so storytelling how many by show of
hands know that i love storytelling yeah
we all know this storytelling is a
weapon that i want you all to use in
your life
okay and my storytelling skills started
early and i really thought about why
it's such a passion for me and there are
proof points along the way one i was a
very avid reader growing up i used to
read a book a night and um for me it
taught me about dialogues and emotions
and interactions with people i mean i
think that's why i like psychology too
but you know how everything worked
together and i also was able to
visualize
what things look like i always preferred
books to movies
and then my mother it's crazy it is in
new york city
we'd walk and if a movie had already
started my mom would take my brother and
i in halfway through
i know child abuse right terrible and
we'd sit in the back row and for an hour
i'd have to figure out what the heck is
going on
right and then we'd sit when the movie
was over everyone would leave they only
had five minute intermissions in those
days in the olden days when they had
horse and carriage and we'd stay and i'd
watch the first hour of the movie and
think oh
did i get that right so what this taught
me is i had to figure out the plot draw
inferences
look for verbal and visual cues it was
pretty much strategic communication
right as a youngster
and then i eavesdrop i'm sorry if you
ever see me i'm a big eavesdropper
i like to go and read and eat but i will
be listening in and i'll be trying to
figure out are you on a date are you
fighting
and i'm going to watch your body
language and see does that person seem
happy or not so yes i do it and if you
see me a koopa i am probably
eavesdropping on you
and then okay we all know this right i'm
a pop culture fanatic
i was faded my mother named me after
allison mckenzie from the first soap
opera ever on tv called peyton place so
i was forced to be in pop culture and
media and that mia farrow she was a
great actress at that point and then we
know i have some questionable reading
material but during my tv years i was
paid to read these magazines i had to
look for gossip and stories
and it was important for me to know
who's doing what with whom
don't judge and then i have an
interesting talent where i have read
every every uh issue of people magazine
since its inception i'm really good at
table talk and i'm a lifeline for a lot
of people and who wants to be a
millionaire
so my other storytelling technique is i
love movies and this was my favorite
movie growing up and
my best friend jamie at the time had
never seen it so i forced her to watch
it at home one night on cable and then
the cable went out so i started acting
it out for her and doing all the
dialogues i must have seen it 20 times
then the cable came back on and i was
way ahead of where the movie was so we
started to watch it again and she looks
at me and she goes you are a freak
she's like i feel like i've seen this
movie already it's crazy you know every
line
so what it showed was my recall of
dialogue my ability to act out scenes
visual communication and to change my
voice for each character some vocal
variety shown thrown in so there you go
again strategic communication
when you tell a story this is what
you're telling people i want you to know
who i am
i want you to know why i care about what
i care about and why i do what i do
and i want you to know my strengths but
also my quirks
and i want you to know what makes me
different from everybody else out there
maybe through my life experience maybe
through my challenges
and
my story is going to prove my
credibility to you
even though i did something that makes
no sense ten years ago i learned
something from it
all right where's erin raise your hand
okay aaron knows the story
erin was born the year of the missouri
floods and i told the story in strategic
communication she's like allison not
really that resonates because i was born
i'm like the story's for you erin
so for those of you who haven't heard it
good morning america sent me to the
missouri floods and
this wasn't my favorite job was to book
live guests during um
big events like floods but my first day
i was in the helicopter and i'm with the
crew and we're taking pictures looking
just like this of just the
the tops of houses on water and it was
just a very horrifying experience
to go over this all this water and then
my job was to go to the red cross
shelter
find a family and convince them to come
with our crew back to their house to
rescue pets or personal belongings
so
i went to the red cross shelter i talked
to the head of the fire department i got
a boat
and then i had to find a family
and there was this man standing against
a wall and his family was sitting on the
ground next to him and i went over to
him and i said hi i'm from good morning
america i have a crew we have a boat
would you like to go back to your house
and maybe rescue some of your personal
items
oh well he started to scream at me he
said how dare you
you want to exploit me at the worst time
in my life for national tv
i've lost everything i'm homeless
you're going to go home in three days to
your warm house
but i'm homeless
and i just let him go on and on and when
he was done
i put my hand on his arm and i said i am
so sorry
please accept my apology if i made this
any worse for you
i wish you luck god bless you and i
walked away and about a minute later i
feel this tap on my shoulder and it's
the man and he's like so how would it
work with the boat and the crew
and so my lesson which a lot of my class
has heard already is that storytelling
goes both ways he needed to tell me his
story and i needed to listen
he needed to get it off his chest and be
heard
and i needed to understand where he was
coming from and when that trust was
built
then he wanted to do it and by the way
he went back
it was a great experience for him and he
did rescue personal belongings
and the executive producer called me and
said that was a great segment but that
wasn't the point and i always think back
to this as not doing the right thing
so if i were to do it now or even a few
years after that because i think i was
only about 22 or 23 at the time i would
have said hi i'm allison kluger i'm from
good morning america i am so sorry for
what you're going through
i don't know if this will help you at
all but i have a boat and a crew would
you like to try to get something from
your house and would you like to show
america what is going on here
so we can get more support
that is how i would have approached it
but sometimes you have to fumble
right to learn the right way to do
something
and i always try to say i never make the
same mistake twice hopefully
so it was a big learning lesson
bob marcus who guests in reputation
management says
if i don't know how you've struggled how
can i connect to you
so again it's that compassion it's
asking people questions why are you
upset what can i do
that's where the connection comes in
so many of you know i teach with tyra
and we had gary vaynerchuk come in to
talk about social media and where to put
your story
and the reassuring news from gary was
that um you don't have to use social
media
but if you are pick a platform that
works for you
whether it's instagram and it's visual
or facebook um or whether you're in
service of somebody and you want to
promote them
but he said if you're going to do it
stick with it and be on top of it but
it's very important for you know for you
to know where to take your story and how
to broadcast it
you also need to know how long to tell
your story
so for some people
just 30 seconds might be enough of your
narrative just the high points or a
minute and a half
or three minutes or sometimes five
minutes but if you don't know your
audience and you tell a really long
story you're going to lose them and
they're going to be frustrated so this
is a really important point
in my classes personal branding and
strategic pivoting
i make sure that my last assignment is
that my students deliver a minute and a
half narrative
for personal branding it's who i am what
i've done and why i'm going to move into
this personal brand and how it's going
to be of service to you strategic
pivoting is what i've done who i am why
i want to pivot and how it will benefit
you very similar but the exercise is if
you can tell your narrative in a minute
and a half
someone else can take that story and
carry it somewhere else where someone
can be of service to you and can create
a new opportunity
so
this project was done in a tv station
before covid and they'd go on live
television
and have to do this narrative and it was
broadcast
so would you like to hear let's hear
some narratives i know some of my
students have seen this but it's worth
seeing it again so this is from project
uh
[Laughter]
hi i'm nancy and i love to live life out
loud
from the necklaces i love to rock to the
melon and i proudly wear on my skin
color and vibrancy is such a huge part
of who i am
but it hasn't always been that way
i was born with a disability in my arm
and my spinal cord called klimke's palsy
before i even knew my name
doctors put limits on what i could
achieve when they told my parents i
could never live independently
but i refused to believe that and i
rebelled
i saw how vibrant i could be and i grew
a passion for helping other people see
that their own vibrancy
through photography
photography has shown me that i'm so
much bigger than this body and it's
allowed me to connect with people in
deep and intimate ways
i built my company okosanko to share the
stories of women of color it's been my
absolute honor to share their vibrancy
with the world
and it's my big hairy scary dream
to take this company from being about
photography to a lifestyle brand
think
cookware and interior design
but designed with the needs and wants of
women in color in mind
i want to help other women expose their
true color in every aspect of their life
every time i see this i'm moved
you know so much about nancy now you
know she had a challenge you know she
loves photography you know she wants to
create a lifestyle brand
and there's enough there that you could
seriously just go and talk about nancy
to someone else and promote her she also
was the embodiment of what she said with
the beautiful colorful necklace she was
wearing
when she finished this class she took a
black and white picture of everyone in
our class and gave it to us and she took
that one to me it's one of my favorite
head shots because of course my hair
looks awesome
good evening coaches my name is ross
pomerantz and i'm in the process of
pivoting from enterprise sales into
something
far more disappointing to my parents
comedy writing
last week i did a poll for 20 of my
closest friends and family and i asked
them what they thought my greatest
strength was
20 out of 20 said humor
now if that wasn't enough 10 years ago i
was voted the 5th funniest person in my
family behind my brother my dad my
sister stuffed animal chester and our
blind pet parakeet so yes i have been
destined for comedic greatness for a
long time now
the other strength that popped up was
discipline which undoubtedly comes from
my background playing baseball where my
only regret was that i didn't get a
chance to strike that man out
now between humor and discipline i've
been put in a very unique position
my pilot started seven years ago when i
started making comedy videos online
i created an alter ego a persona called
corporate bro
a parody on silicon valley sales life
a parody on
my life
fast forward to today i have nearly 120
000 fans i've gotten millions of views
across all social media platforms and i
even get invited to go speak at tech
companies which is utterly ridiculous
now that isn't where it ends i don't
think
the last year and a half i spent writing
a pilot tv show with my younger brother
which frankly i think is our best work
which is rare for me to say because
frankly i've hated everything i've ever
done
so
alex if you know anyone at wme allison
you know anyone in the tv industry at
all or jenny you know someone at google
tv i would be honored to share it with
them
so i'm very excited to take my launch
because i have absolutely no idea where
i'm going to land thank you
fabulous right do you know a lot about
ross did he not role model the humor i
mean you heard we were a natural laugh
track alex and the author jenny from
pivot and i were hysterical
there was so much in there it was a tad
too long
but he could shorten it but the point
was you understood what the building
steps were to this pivot and his
credibility and he really knows his
narrative and he's told me he's used in
a lot of different forms
so people tell you who you are
i was at penn my freshman year in
creative writing i love creative writing
but my teacher biff russ hated me and i
was always like the goody two shoes in
english because i'm not a math student
as we all know
and but she hated my writing and i'd
always get low grades and finally i
found out why and she said alison you
have very complex thoughts but you write
like people magazine i'm not kidding i
had a people magazine in my backpack at
that time but i did not whip it out and
i was humiliated
i felt that i was stupid i felt that i
was going to fail and that she didn't
appreciate anything i wrote but she told
me what my brand was at a very young age
messaging for the masses
taking complex thoughts
and funneling them so it's a very
top-line message
and that is what you do in tv that is do
what you do in coaching and that's when
you do an education so
biff did me a favor i just didn't listen
hard enough and i was too young to
appreciate that wisdom but i go back to
it a lot and think wow i think my
superpower showed up really early
so think about what someone says about
you
you're so good at this or i wish you i
wish i could do this the way you did it
whatever it is think about what people
tell you because they can see how you
land on them and they might be able to
encourage you in ways you can't do for
yourself
so this is my son logan he was about
eight in this picture
and
this story is really about when he was
four have you heard of bing nursery
school i think here at stanford okay so
getting my sons into being was harder
than getting into the gsb
i'm not kidding i wrote a kick-ass
letter and i got them in because i
really felt it would be the best school
for them and i was at orientation and
when they were talking about the half
acre of play room and play and
everything they talked about and i was
almost crying thinking oh my god i'm so
happy my son is here this is such a
privilege
so about two weeks into it i went to
drop logan off and the head teacher
sarah who's really tall in english
pulled me over she goes allison
logan learned a new word and i'm like
great let's hear the brilliance
she goes it's
so i like go pale and i'm like uh-huh
and she goes do you have any idea where
he may have heard that word
so i say i'm sure it's from me
i said where else would he hear it i
said i don't know when and where but it
was probably me
she's like it's okay other kids curse
but we just don't want you to think they
learned it here
and don't worry about it and i said no
problem and i went back to my car and
cried i'm like i'm in the best school
and now they think i'm the worst mom my
kid's cursing up a storm so i go to pick
him up later on and sarah calls me over
alison
did you go to your car and cry
i said yeah i did and she's like allison
she that's why we love you because
you're the only parent who has ever
admitted it was them
this happens all the time she says we
trust you you're so endearing and we
became so close and i ended up doing the
auction it bang and the annual fun but
that was where my trust was built and
sarah is still a dear friend
so the more transparent you are the more
people trust you we know this from the
trust radar in reputation management
there's shame in hiding the truth it's
much bigger burden on you to try to hide
who you are and what you've done
own it your candor will inspire others
to also be honest
all right don't be afraid to share your
truth
i was at qualtrics a few years ago
before kovid and i got to see three of
my heroes oprah and to richard branson
and obama and then this gentleman came
out to speak his name was
billy mcdermott ceo of
sap i didn't know who he was i was in an
audience of 11 000 people so i'm sure i
wasn't alone but he came out very good
looking guy salt and pepper hair but
wearing sunglasses and he sat down in
this dark auditorium and started talking
to andy the moderator and all i could
think of is like why is he wearing
sunglasses like is he too cool for us is
he jack nicholson like what's he trying
to say because i'm always looking at
signals and i'm so distracted by his
glasses that i do something i rarely do
which is i pulled up my phone which no
one should ever do when they're in an
auditorium
and i look at my phone and i look him up
and sure enough he's had an accident he
was walking down the stairs and he
tripped and he was holding a glass and
it shattered and a shard of glass went
into his eye and he had all these all
these surgeries
so what i was thinking was if i had
coached him i would have said look billy
you've got to know your audience you've
11 000 people 10 won't know who you are
and they're going to make assumptions so
before you start talking you say hey i
just want to let you know i had some
surgeries on my eye i need to wear
glasses i'm not giving you any shade
and then you go on and then all of a
sudden you feel empathy you feel closer
you feel connected and you're not
distracted from the reason he's actually
there
so the lesson is
say who you are
share your experiences be authentic and
don't make excuses don't be embarrassed
for who you are your stories tell a tale
and they help people connect you
so why should you create a narrative i
know you've heard me say this many times
it's more interesting to start with a
story people can carry your story
it helps you connect and it's you at
your most authentic
what makes you stand out in a crowd
you're all brilliant here what makes you
stand out each of you has something that
makes you stand out
so you have to figure out your
differentiating factor your secret sauce
is what i like to call it your zone of
genius
um what do people again tell you about
yourself
all of you who've done the p-wrap right
oh my god i've apologized everyone had
to take the surveys but you learned what
do people say about you when you figure
out your secret sauce and superpower you
need to leverage it
so number nine it's not what happens
it's how you deal with it reputation
management started that way it is my
mantra it will probably go on my
gravestone
happens
it's going to happen how are you dealing
with it how you deal with it says way
more about you than what actually
happened
so what if you have a reputation for
being unapproachable sarcastic arrogant
late
blaming others being too quiet and not
speaking up not joining in in activities
well you can behave your way to a new
reputation this is from jill peterson
when he and when he guested in my class
but an example for you is let's say you
know someone you're someone who is
habitually late
and you know it's kind of funny and it's
quirky and people think ah this is you
know this is this person but what it's
saying is your time isn't as valuable as
my time is i don't respect your time and
after a while doesn't it's not cute
anymore so what i said to someone as i
said you can change this reputation by
being consistently early
so get to the next meeting early and
everyone's going to say oh what are you
doing here early you're always late and
you'll say no no i'm going to be early
from now and they're like okay then you
show up the next meeting and you're
early like oh you're still doing the
early thing huh
and you'll say yup still doing the early
thing and then you keep showing up early
and early and all of a sudden that old
reputation of being late has now been
put to bed
and you don't even have a reputation for
it anymore
what i love about this example is you
are not stuck in a reputation you can
always be fluid
and tweak something that you think you
could do better and then consistently
show up and you will create that new
reputation
i really believe in choosing to engage
in difficult conversations i think many
of us would rather
sweep it under the rug or hope it passes
by
but from my experience people hold on to
these things and that becomes a fixed
bias about you
and so have those hard conversations
because i don't think you want to leave
things unsaid and especially as you are
getting ready to leave here if there's
anybody who you feel you have a
misunderstanding with and you think oh
it's too late to confront that
it's not i called up amy that producer
from the home shopping network last year
after not speaking to her for over 20
years and said can we talk about what
happened
and we talked about and she apologized
to me
and it was a hard conversation that i
avoided for a very long time but it
really healed me
it also teaches you how to verbalize
complex thoughts you should be able to
have difficult conversations at work and
in your personal life
and not be intimidated
by the emotions involved
it teaches you how to advocate for
yourself i was really hurt by this but i
want to hear
what you were thinking
it also creates trust because people
will know that you're an honest
forthright person
and it helps you control your own
narrative
so
it's not what you say it's how you say
it i think i said this earlier you can
say anything to anyone if you say it in
a way that is kind compassionate and
straightforward and candid
i do believe you can spin anything into
a positive
and so let's say you got fired and
you're embarrassed and you don't want to
talk about this well you have two ways
of doing it one you can say this job is
terrible like someone who's interviewing
you and says why were you only there for
six months you say well you know i was
promised this and it never happened and
they were terrible
what does that say about you how about
you say you know what when i went to
that job i thought i was going to be
doing this and this
and it didn't work out that way but in
the six months i was there i learned
this this and this and now i'm even more
prepared to be here with you
so how you message something
tells people about you but you can put a
positive spin on anything even if it's
not the greatest experience i've had
jobs that i had to squeeze into
round peg into a square hole
and that doesn't really make sense
but you know what i would always try to
find one thing of value maybe meeting a
new person or a mentor a new skill
so again we're back to if not you then
who
and i want you to opt in and figure it
out
okay all of us have opportunities that
are presented to us but many times we
say it's not us i'm not ready for that
and that's because it's scary to opt in
or we're feeling lost in life and we
don't want to take anything new on or
we're doing what we're doing to make
others happy but we're not thinking
about what we really want
we're afraid to take a risk we're not
feeling authentic and we have impostor
syndrome but i'm going to remind you
that when you're asked to opt-in to do
something the deliverable is never five
minutes later so if someone says i want
you to do this project or i want you to
get this promotion i want you to go on
this off site and you're like
just think okay say yes thank you and
then you go break it down and you can
research it ask questions
fill in the knowledge gaps but you were
all sitting here the most capable human
beings you're here because you know how
to do this
so just take those opportunities when
they come
don't give all that negative self-talk
in your head
and say you know what i'll figure it out
i'm smart enough to figure it out
so use your origin story to create your
narrative you're all thinking ah what's
my narrative well you go back to your
origin story a lot of you know this
forgive me if you this is going to be
redundant i'm going to go through it
quickly but some of you don't know it so
using my own experience i went to penn i
interned at tv stations i started at
good morning america three days later i
worked there eight years i went to the
shopping network i got on air i sold
barbecues
and after um after that i went into the
control room and i led the whole
show which i really loved and then i was
wooed away to another shopping network
where i was the executive producer 16
hours of live television i was the face
of the network i created shows
i hired and fired and then this was me
doing a promo
let's see
hi i'm allison kluger your host for
designers corner here at gsm we get new
york city designers to bring in their
jewelry and all the jewelry is like a
piece of art each one is handcrafted
with semi-precious stones unique designs
and you can't find it anywhere else you
don't have to wander around the streets
downtown looking for that very special
piece of jewelry we're going to bring it
to you we're going to bring you the
piece of jewelry that's beautiful
interesting that you can't find anywhere
else with a price that you can afford so
be sure to catch me here at gsn the
smart shoppers channel
right yeah
[Applause]
someone had to do it right
and you don't want to wander around
looking for that very special piece of
jewelry let me do it for you
anyway um
then i was wood over by the the view
barbara walters was my idol i had known
her when i was an intern and i always
wanted to work with her i know that
she's old and you probably don't know
her but she was a pioneer
and i was like the thrill of my life and
then my husband went to the gsb and i
had to move to to here and be an so or
an sob and
i had to support us
and go into i started a dot com for
women i was a com disaster open tv
snapped me up i was an executive
producer there then when i finished i
did a year with al gore and i helped him
set up current tv i took that job just
to work with him not for the money
because believe me there was no money
and then after seven and i'm sorry nine
in vitros and three years of trying i
had trouble and more trouble
and i took seven years off to raise them
and i did start my own media consulting
business but it was far and few between
the amount of times i actually worked
because i was the sole caretaker my
husband was starting up companies and
then i came to this place
which is a very trite photo but it
really says what i felt
and a lot of you might be there right
now or in 10 years you might be there
and i just had to say what's my
narrative right so i figured these are
the things i'm really good at and no
matter where i go and what i do i'm
going to bring this to it
so don't be afraid to repackage yourself
there are times you're going to be
pivoting there are times you're going to
recreate yourself
but everything you need is there you
just have to cherry pick it out so
here's the exercise that um i teach in
project u and strategic pivoting so
again many of you know it but for those
who don't it's called cake and icing i
visualize this
exercise from this book
and cake is what you really do well it's
your rational value it's your functional
skills your icing is what people say
about you and how they describe you and
together they make your strong brand but
they also enable you to tell your story
so now with all those jobs i told you
about listed up here what i do is i
write down my cake underneath each one
what are the talents what are what's
what's my functional benefits i can do
and then you see what keeps popping up
well i always create content
i'm innovative
oops
i'm problem solving
i coach talent
and i'm an expert at messaging
look how many times that pops up in my
weird timeline right and then my icing
this is what people would say about me
and if you don't know those words you
ask your friends do a survey i'm really
i really
recommend surveys
and so these are the things that i also
deliver what people think now if i were
to create a narrative i might go to each
one of these steps and pick out an
anecdote or a story under each one that
shows my skills that proves my
credibility that shows a failure and a
triumph
and that is how you can curate stories
for your narrative
so present the solution not the
suggestion i see i'm running out of time
i'm gonna have to be super fast how many
people know the tyra story before i go
into it show of hands okay i have to
tell it then i'm gonna be really quick
tyra came here at cemex i was in the
front row i watched all her shows and
she talked about personal branding and
she was so amazing and talked about her
roles changing and i'm sitting here
going i got to teach with her and i
forced my way backstage with no
permission and i have a 30-second
narrative and i say hi tyra i'm allison
kluger i teach here i was a tv producer
at the view in good morning america and
i know you've been on both shows i want
to teach a course with you on personal
branding a compressed course what do you
think
and she was like i don't know and i'm
like no i have a great idea and i said i
learned more from you in one hour and
she's like okay and she gives me her
card and we make an appointment for a
week later in that week i go back and i
start creating the whole course all six
classes what are the textbooks that i
want to read who are going to be the
guests what's every segment about
i'm going to
stream it live on facebook to be
differentiated i'm going to come out of
a live tv station for the final project
we'll do visual branding and i put it
all together with all the compressed
course dates that were available and
then i talked to her again for a few
hours and i'm like so here's the outline
what do you want to do and she was
amazing i can do this and i can do that
and blah blah and she was like the most
brilliant marketer i have ever met
and she made it easy and said okay this
is all great and i said give me the two
weeks you can do and you have to be here
every day and she's like okay and give
me a backup she's okay then i went and
redid the whole proposal and then i
anticipated what all the pushback would
be from the dean
and then i
thought about how i'm going to handle
all that and then i went to the
assistant dean of the business school
and i said i want to teach a course with
tyra banks she's a businesswoman here's
her proof this is the course this is how
it's going to benefit our students this
is how it's going to be different from
all the other courses these are the
takeaways these are our textbooks these
are our guests and he asked me every
question i anticipated starting with
tyra's not our brand i don't think she's
the right person i'm like oh she is
and he said yes
so
the lesson here is did i already say no
there she is there she is
i'm going to go back quickly present the
solution not the suggestion
and the reason i say this is that if i
had gone the day after tyre was here and
went to the assistant dean and said you
know i think i want to teach with tyra i
have this idea he would have said no
absolutely not and i would have been
dead in the water
and that would have been it for me so if
you want to create change for yourself
don't complain about things don't
identify the problems create the
solutions
just go to an interview and say you know
i've looked at your website and you're
missing this and i'd love to take over
and i want to be in charge and this is
the budget but this is just a tip for
those of you who aren't as bold or need
more time or introverted but it's worked
for me a lot and it's probably my number
one tip and i did it with alex i created
the course
ahead of time alex was available to
guest speak i wasn't sure they'd let him
but the course now exists and
that's what we did that's my tip so
i am telling you to be authentic you and
i'm telling you all these things you
need to do that might push you out of
your comfort zone right
so finally my last story
is
i was crying at good morning america i
was about two months in i was almost 21
and this woman sonia selby wright an
english producer i was scared of her too
she pulled me in her office and she shut
the door and she said allison i don't
ever want to see you crying do you know
why and i was like uh-huh and
intuitively i knew why but i knew she
was going to tell me and she says
because you're young you're female and
you're attractive and no one is going to
trust you no one is going to give you
responsibility and no one is going to
think you're reliable
she goes if you're having a bad day you
come in my office and you can close the
door but if someone says to you how are
you you say i'm great
do you understand i said yes and she was
like get out of here
and so she threw me out of the office
and of course what did i want to do
cry
but i didn't but this was an epiphany
for me
and this is the how i became the leader
i want to be i wanted to be reliable i
wanted to be respected i wanted to be
given the hard work and so i became
unflappable and they'd say go to allison
she can take care of her go to allison
she's really easy to work with go to
allison she's a problem solver and then
i i went to jobs that i was on air and
in the control room where anything could
go wrong so by showing up every day the
way i wanted to show up is how i created
the reputation and how i became the
leader i want to be even though i was a
very shy kid and obviously i cry a lot
i still do but you know that's how i
showed my fear
so act like the leader you want to be
and it becomes authentic
everyone can do it you're not cheating
yourself out of your true personality
these are the leaders who i want to be
like barbara walters for her work ethic
oprah for transparency obama for
integrity and empathy
michelle obama inspirational and
powerful and then of course ruth bader
ginsburg for breaking barriers those
were my north stars figure out who yours
are
so what are my takeaways for today
lead with love compassion over
aggression when down do for others
storytelling is a secret weapon
differentiate yourself
choose to engage in those hard
conversations
spin it into a positive present the
solution not the suggestion
opt in and figure it out later and act
like the leader you want to be because
if not you
then who
thank you
um
kenny
thank you everybody
thank you so much allison i think we
have time for one or two quick questions
and then you can probably catch a
girlfriend outside for any fall i'm
excited
not nervous for those questions i don't
know who's got a question to stump me
yes
the mic is actually right behind you if
you want in the cup holder oh how
convenient did you plant that person
hello okay hi allison uh thank you so
much so i think one of the greatest
gifts from coming to the gsb is just the
platform it gives us to
um you know share a message or just a
cause that we really care about i love
to hear how you think about when you
choose to step in and out of the public
eye and how you manage that and also to
that how you stay authentic when so much
of what we're pitching is sometimes to
our loved ones and to our masses and
sometimes feels inconsistent like how do
we close that gap thank you for that
question um i don't always choose
sometimes i'm chosen
and then i have to opt in
and so i would say that i've had
imposter syndrome probably my entire
first 45 years of my life
i'm only 30 so i don't really know how
that math works but
but many times i've been tapped on the
shoulder to do something or someone's
come to me and said allison we want you
to be on air and i will battle with the
fear and i'll force myself to do it and
by the way the reality is never as scary
as what you think it is we build it up
in our heads
so the outward facing me is just from
challenging myself
when i started teaching here i had
another epiphany and my epiphany is i'm
going to say yes to everything at this
point in my career i know what i'm good
at
i worked really hard to create a course
here and if i can't do it i'm going to
say i can't do it or i'm going to find
someone who can
so in being authentic about it i just am
very clear of what i'm not good at we
all know i'm not going to do accounting
and budgeting
but i know what i'm really good at and i
lean into it i hope that answers your
question
yes
oh chris chris is right behind you
perfect
hi
miriam hi you made it it was amazing
thank you oh yeah thanks for inviting me
uh my my question is about your slides
on transparency and being in front up
front with people i'm just wondering is
that always the case or has a brand time
where it's better to not speak up or say
something on your mind in a certain
situation
you know i've grown into that as well
thank you for that great question miriam
um i'm a great believer that
the more you are transparent or have
radical candor as people in reputation
management know the gift you're giving
people they don't have to work so hard
to figure you out and i've always said
like some of my students are actually
shy or introverted and yet when they did
the reputation survey people would say
you seem arrogant or aloof or you don't
care about me and i say that's because
you're shy and you're quiet but people
are making assumptions about you because
they just want to be friends with you
and they think you're rejecting them
so sometimes it's good to say you know
i'm i'm not the most social person but
i'm really happy to be here
but front load the information you want
just like billy mcdermott
there are different shades of
transparency if it's going to diminish
your power in a job then i might find a
better way to say something
but
i always believe that eventually the
truth outs
and if you're working so hard to be
someone you're not it's going to be
exhausting and i think ultimately we all
want to be accepted and appreciated for
who we truly are and what we bring to
the table
and for the things we feel insecure
about we can ask for help but if you
don't broadcast and say you know what
i'm not so good
with this
you know i need some help everyone wants
to help you so i hope that answered your
question i think that transparency is a
personal thing
but i'm a pretty open book and it's
worked well for me except when i called
amy a that was not good but i
learned from that
thank you for the question
thank you so much allison thank you all
i love you all
you